bonsoir le château du rocher dans le
loir et cher à fred weill est un peu
particulier vous le voyez derrière moi
il a évolué au fil du temps du moyen âge
jusqu'au xxème siècle mais sa vraie
particularité c'est que il a été acheté
par un particulier en 1998 aux enchères
et qu'ensuite il a été transformé en
château des énigmes en 2014
alors on vous montre le concept et on se
retrouve tout après avec son
propriétaire
olfa et ses quatre enfants découvrent
l'histoire du moyen-âge à travers une
chasse aux indices
première étape trouver une bouteille
d'hydromel offerte au jeune willy en
formation de chevalier elle est belle
elle n'a pas de bouchon elle est à côté
d'un verre a répondu à la première
question c'est bon oui acteurs tout au
long des trois heures du parcours les
enfants apprennent son s'en rendre
compte il y en a de mon pote à lui 5
franchement c'est bien pour les enfants
c'est convivial et puis ça les aide à
réfléchir et je trouve c'est top
alpha est venue avec un groupe du centre
social de pithiviers
au cours de la visite tous les sens des
enfants sont sollicités
dans le château les familles découvrent
les blasons les loisirs et les étoffes
de l'époque médiévale nous à
l'accompagnement scolarité un truc qui
est important c'est travail sur la
parentalité et sur l'interculturalité
du coup parentalité c'étaient les tester
l'effet revenu aussi les familles les
parents et de leur apporter quelque
chose au niveau culturel ça peut être
voilà on a travaillé toute l'année sur
des projets donc en fin d'année il a
récompensé avec une sortie culturelle
pour qu'ils puissent voir autre chose et
accéder à des loisirs qui n'ont pas
accédé habituellement
[Musique]
le château du rocher eux étant des plus
anciens du loir et cher le site datent
du milieu du xiiie siècle remanié
plusieurs fois il prend l'apparence
d'une villa à l'italienne au xviiie
siècle
longtemps restée un hôtel-restaurant il
est racheté aux enchères de 100000 euros
en 1998 son propriétaire le transforme
en château aux énigmes en 2014 ce qui
séduit 25000 visiteurs chaque année
j'aime bien château puis j'aime mieux
les mouvements aussi c'est rigolo de de
découvrir le château de mercey mu on
préfère visiter comme ça en me disant
que en regardant plaintes traitées comme
au japon
chambord depuis peu un ftp games a vu le
jour au dernier étage ce qui permet de
générer les entrées tout au long de
l'année
[Musique]
je suis avec le propriétaire du château
du rocheux monsieur laurent hier
chantons bonjour bonjour alors dites moi
pourquoi vous avez acheté ce château en
98 le château ça a été un coup de coeur
en fête ce château était en déshérence
il a été mis en vente aux enchères j'ai
pu apporter acquéreurs et voilà nous
avons remporté l'enchère et ils sont
arrivés en 98 ça a été notre coupe du
monde que l'on a remporté ici
et puis l' aventure a commencé avec ma
famille qui est mes enfants étaient tous
jeunes de 2 à 7 ans et nous nous sommes
installés nous avons fait un peu des
chambres d'hôtes des locations de salles
mais ce n'était pas suffisant pour
entretenir l'ensemble du domaine donc
derrière on a recherché une idée qui
permettait de maintenir et de développer
notre activité afin de continuer
d'entretenir et de de pouvoir en vivre
un peu plus facilement
vous avez créé le château des énigmes et
là où nous avons décidé de par une
rencontre avec un propriétaire qui avait
créé le concept de faire le château des
énigmes ici aujourd'hui près de 25000
visiteurs nous rendent visite chaque
année et nous sommes très satisfaits
vous permet d'en vivre aujourd'hui alors
d'en vivre
pas complètement en tout cas mais ça
nous permet d'entretenir de pouvoir
développer cette année nous avons changé
le parcours de jeu ait investi environ
deux cent mille euros de 200000 euros 2
d'investissement pour régner au sein
pour que le public plus avoir de
nouvelles énigmes
merci beaucoup merci à aucun m'écoute
merci c'est fini pour aujourd'hui au
château des énigmes ne ment on se
retrouvera dans le loir-et-cher toujours
à tour de sologne au château de
villesavin bonne soirée